24時間で都道府県何個行ける
の日本にお住まいの皆さんこんにちははみ
社長です都道府県に皆さんいると思うん
ですよ何県にいますで日本にはね47個都
道府県っていうこの日本地図を47個に
分けられてるんですけれども僕はふと思い
ました24時間で何個都道府県が生きるの
か日本一周の旅とかよく言うんですけれど
もあれ結構時間かけてこう泊まりながら
ゆっくりすると思うんですけども遅い遅い
本気出せば1日でもうちょっと1周いける
かいけないかぐらいどれぐらいいけるか
本当想像もつかないんですけれども
しっかりですね24時間動き続けて何個都
道府県回れるのか自分の体を思って検証し
てみたいと思いますルール説明しますまず
どんな手を使ってもオッケーです私初め
社長がこう移動するのにどんな手を使って
もオッケーもう車使ってもオッケー
ジェット機使ってもオッケー新幹線使って
もオッケーフェリ使ってもオッケーシャリ
使ってもオッケーどんな手を使ってでも
大丈夫
ですちなみに今のところノープランです
なんかが考えると作戦建ててやりそうだっ
たからあえて知識ゼでえ始めたいと思い
ますスタート地点は静岡県ですどこでも
良かったんですけどなんか静岡なんやがん
や日本のこうなんか真ん中っぽいし住ん
でるのでちょうどいいかなと思って静岡
から始めさせていただきますでどうやっ
たらその都道府県に行ったことになるのか
新幹線で通りましたとか飛行機でこう上
行きましたとかダメですそれはなんかその
場に行ったってことにはなんかならない気
がしててちゃんとその都道府県の地に足を
つければその都道府県に行ったことになり
ます車でバンって移動してもいいですけど
サービスエリアとかなんか道の抜かわかん
ないですけどそこにちゃんと降りて足つい
たらクリア新幹線とかもなんか停車駅とか
で一瞬降りて停車駅ちゃんと降りて足つけ
ばそれでクリアなんせ僕がしっかり両足で
地面につくことが条件になります開始時刻
が今日の0時から明日の24時24時間
[音楽]
です死ぬかな死ぬかなまで移動中寝たり
すればいいですしねなん体力と相談して
ちゃんと休むことも大事だと思うんで
とりあえず可能な限りちょっと24時間
いろんな届け回ってみたいと思います
そして来い今回の企画のために2匹の歩兵
を準備し
ましよろしくお願いしますお願いします俺
が1番怖いのは多分最初普通に俺の車で
移動すると思うだよ色々まずね乗り捨てを
起きる気がしてて新幹線に乗るとかさ飛行
機に乗るとかすると絶対ダメじゃん車その
車を回収するとかそういう人が絶対いると
思うので2人はそういうあの
乗り捨て要因なるほどできるだけついてき
て欲しいです可能な限りはい必要すねレタ
か返さないレタが5台とか6台とか出て
くると非常にまずいのでもし乗り捨てとか
何かあった時に一応2人だけその保険で
連れてきますのでよろしくお願いしますお
願いしますちに何個いけると思う24時間
で15件15僕は半分行ってほしいですね
僕はですね
45沖縄と北海道は多分無理なのよ行った
時点で往復なんか端っこだいぶきついと
思うから沖縄北海道はちょっと俺今回無理
かなと思ってるんでマジでうまくいけば
45いけるかなて思ってますま実際どう
やって回るかとか作戦はちゃんと0時に
なってから考えたいと思うので0時まで
しばらくお待ちくださいでは行き
ましょうもう24時になった瞬間俺はこの
家を飛び出しスタートして都道府県
なるべく回りますここから24時間俺の
止まらない旅が始まる
ぜあスタートスタート
スタート着替えます着替えます着替えます
なんで着替えてなかったんだ着替えてから
スタートだよし準備完了です早速行ってき
ますえまずどこ行こっかなどこ行くかは
まだ決めてないんですよあ危ねえあ旅
終わるとこだった今あぶねえ今床滑って
普通にコンクリに頭打つとこでした危ない
はいこれで静岡はクリアですはいこうやっ
て血に足つけばその都道府県は行ったって
ことになるのでこれで静岡は行きましたは
社長の家の前です住所静岡県静岡
市来ないでください車乗りましょう地図で
言うと本当静岡県の静岡市にいるんですよ
どうしよっかな何も考えず乗っちゃった
からなま近さで言うとえやっぱ東京に
向かってきたいのよねなんかさギュっと
密集してるところに行った方がいいと思う
んのよまず車で行けるとこまででそこら辺
ぐるって回れたらあとはワンチャン飛行機
に乗ってなんか遠くに行っちゃうとか関西
とか九州とか今静でしょ俺的に群馬栃木
茨城埼玉東京神奈川千葉ありぐわって回
行きたいのよ長野とかでかいし新潟も
でかいからなとりあえずじゃあ山梨噛んで
から神川行きます行けんのこれ本当にどう
しようどうしよう攻めの姿勢が求められん
じゃないですかそうだよねこれでも山梨
入っときたいんだよなとりあえず山梨
向かいます1回近いよね隣すよねだよね
ちょっととりあえず行きますねもうじゃ
出発進行本当に決めてないんですよ何も0
時スタート絶対したいと思って何も考えず
に来てしまったの
ででも静岡から山梨めっちゃ近いのよ確か
高速乗ってまず極力神奈川寄りまで行っ
ちゃおうよし行くぞまずは山梨県
だ高速道路に行けますたたこれで東京か
埼玉で東京方面に向かい
ますこうだこうだよねこうだよねえ府向だ
よねこだよねこの道をまっすぐ行けば山梨
甲府の方に迎えるはずですちょっとね府
まで行くか途中で引き返せるポイントが
あるかまだ分からないのでとりあえず進み
ます誰もおらん
なお梨あ見て山梨来ました山梨来まし
たすごい今0時41分開始から40分で2
つ目の県に入りました山梨県です山梨の皆
さんこんにちは見てる
かこれだとまだダメなんだよねこの後山梨
県に俺は足をつけなければいけないので
ちょっと降りれそうなポイントを探します
降り
ます見ろ右手にローソンがあるこの
ローソンで降りろ山のロソ発見
[音楽]
です
山梨県到着しました2つ目の県山梨県到着
しましたえローソ南部福祉店でございます
え南部の皆さんこんにちは来ました夜中な
のでそんな大きな声出さないですけども
山梨来たので山梨のローソン堪能したいと
思います行ってき
ますただいま
ですまたミルク買いましたでこんなことし
てる場合にちゃうんですなるべく走り回り
たいからでもさせっかく行くならちょっと
ぐらい楽しんだ方がいいよねさすがにさ来
てバイバイって悲しいから飲んですぐまた
次のところ向かいたいと思います行き
ましょうえっと1回静岡戻んないといけな
いっぽいので高速的に戻って神奈川で足
付けて東京行っちゃいましょうか海老名と
かだよね多分降りそうなポイントえ1時に
なりました1時間経過しましたはいはい1
時間以内に2個回れてるからいいペース
じゃないですかこれとりあえず神奈川
目指して行き
ます静岡県入りましたはい静岡県に戻って
きまし
たこれで静岡から高速に乗ってえ東京方面
に向かいますまずは神奈川県かなえっと1
時24分です藤川サービスエリアから乗っ
て海老名に向かい
ます
[音楽]
来ました神奈川県そして今時刻
が2時1分
ですはい2時間経過して神奈川県に入り
ました確実に東京には近づいていってい
ます神奈川でもさなんかさサービスエリア
に降りるのもちょっと預けないの
で横浜行っちゃう行っちゃおうかこれは
行くさやそんなういことやってられへん
この道が空いてる夜が勝負だと思ってるエ
[音楽]
行こうはい到着しましたサービスエリア
海老名です俺が最も使うと言われている
サービスエリアですね金川の横浜行き
たかったね行きたかったすレが倉庫行き
たかったそんな時間もないのでサービス
エリアで済ませましょうよしエビの到着し
まし
たよしよしよし
神奈川到着しまし
た海老名です時前にはつけましたね海老名
いいよねサービスエリア昔ねなんか視聴者
さんが働いてたのよここであの上のご飯屋
さんでお腹減ってるペコペコですえまじ
ちょっとお腹空いてましたじゃちょっと
食べていくかお願いしますちょっとね本当
休憩しながらじゃないと24時間持たない
のでちょっと食べますエビが1番ちょっと
ゲータやんちょっと誰がゲタすか
タマシマ
やゲーただマシマやえまだ誰もいないやん
貸し切りちょっと作戦建てたよでこっから
どうするか順当に行けば東京も行けますで
あの密集してるあの埼玉とかはあの群馬の
そこら辺もバッて行ってそこからどうする
かだねま千葉に成田空港あるからそっから
飛行機で手軽に消そうなとこに遠くにぶっ
てるのは作戦
[音楽]
こち
あ最後忘れ
たえ忘れ
た誰持っ
てこれをくれば東京です今東京に向かっ
てるんですけども高速を降りるタイミング
でなか発生してちょっと遅延を食らってい
ますETCが正常に反応しなかったのかな
この光景はなかなか見れない
よこれやばくないやばいマジで怖いはいお
いしましたはいおしました申し訳ござい
ませんでしたはいえ500にお願いいたし
ますちょすいませんちっちゃい時で藤川
スマートですねバカ相手からお進み
くださいざしましたございます少々お待ち
ください初めてだねこんなの初めてです
くそタイムロスだくそくそ
夜遅くまでお疲れ
[音楽]
様よしヨガパーキングエやってきました
東京ってことだからもっと見せるべきもの
があると思うんですがそんなこと言って
られねえもうスピード命ださっさと次の
場所に向かい
ましょう
[音楽]
はいついに着きましたご覧
ください3座
ですうわお1人死にましたはいえ5時に
なりました皆さんは県境というものをご
存知でしょうか剣とケとの間にはやっぱ
境い目がこうピってあるんですけども中に
は3つの剣がこう重なってる点3つの剣
全部ってる部分それを3件ザって言うん
ですけどもそこに来た方が俺手っ取りん
じゃねていうことで今1時間ちょいぐらい
かな時間ちょいかけて今ですね埼玉群馬
栃木3つともまけるとこにきましたこれ
でかいでしょ中半端にこう回り込むよりも
一気に3元パーンって触れた方が絶対いい
ので埼玉栃群馬3つともコンプリートし
たいと思います行きましょうこっっちっ
ぽいすね行きましょうわ絶対この道だ絶対
この道の奥に3つの剣の境い目があるはず
だああわここっぽくね皆さん見てください
これすごいぞ埼玉県そして栃木県群馬県
すごいなすごい3つの境い目がここにある
[音楽]
埼玉
コレよしよしよしよしよしよしこれで3つ
行きました何個行った5時間経過しまして
今スタートの静岡山梨神奈川東京群馬栃木
埼玉7個来ました1時間1都道府県以上の
ペースで来てますいやこっからどうするか
だよな俺のイメージだと羽田空港か成田
空港っていう空港が結構この関東にあるん
ですけどそこからもう飛びたいのよねどこ
か遠くにまとまって触れる件は結構もう
触ったのでだと茨城と千葉行ったらさ
コンプだよ茨城行って千葉行って千葉の
空港からまどこ行くかだよねで関東が一番
ミしてるからまずここをコンプしてそこ
から飛行機時間あれば当日するのかって
乗ってま東北に行くなり関西に行くなり
四国九州中国地方とかいろんな道があると
思うのでとりあえず関東コンプしよう茨城
千葉行きますまずは茨城県行きます成田
空港千葉県は成田空港目指していきますで
ここにに行く程で茨城県通ればもう最高な
の
よさあルート見せて
くれこのルートは埼玉東京だからダメだ
これはダメなルートですここ通りたいよね
こう行きたいよね距離優先と
かににゃこれは
どうギリ通ってるギこれギリ通ってるのか
これ今成田空港へのルート調べたんです
けどこれどうなんかつくばってさ茨城じゃ
ないっけ茨城すこれで行きましょうお願い
します茨城触りながら成田空港で空にも
行けますこれで一気に茨城県と千葉県行き
たいと思いますでは茨城からの千葉行き
[音楽]
ますよしつば中央で降りようつばで
果たしてどこに行くのか私が行くところは
もちろん
左に見ますマクドナルドです一応調べたら
6時開演開演じゃねえや6時オープンで
書いてあった
[音楽]
けどおかしくなった
か俺だってさ次にも手伝ってもらったけど
ほぼほぼ夜から朝までずっと運転してる
からおかしくなっちゃう
なよっしゃ
え6時ちょっと過ぎですね茨城県到着し
ましたあきも見える見
てなんかめっちゃ朝っぽくていいねえ
マクドナルドつくば上横店に到着しまし
たそして6時ということでマック多分
オープンしてるはずですあそこ食べ
ましょうか買って車でみなり食べよう
ぜ
ってきました朝マックですだいぶ肝も出て
きたね
もうつ食べてる時間もちょっともったい
ないので車で食べながら行きましょう
サーベ寝てたからちょっと運転させて
その間に俺たち食べてちょっと寝ようお
願いしますこれ体力が持たんみんなの分
買った買ったやったついにはこれおお
ありがとうございますテイラテイラサお前
には消毒駅消毒液ソーセージグマフィン
ソーセージグマフィンありがとうござい
ますいただきますいただきます
あわうま運転しながらね移動しながら食べ
ていき
[音楽]
ましょう左方向
です
[音楽]
場県成田国際
空港到着
ですよしよしよしよしよしよし
よしおかしいだろ国際戦だよこれで一応
関東地方は制覇しまし
た今時刻が7時過ぎぐらいですかね7時
ちょっと過ぎでここからどうする
まどの便に乗るかっすもんねそうだよねて
か俺当日に飛行機予約したことないから
分かんないんだどうすればいいのか
ちょっとあの受付とかに聞いてみて乗れる
飛行機があるか聞いてみたいと思いますえ
ここでさっきまで乗ってた車を乗り捨てし
たのでえサーベとはお別れですありがとな
果して国内線こんななか勢いで行って
乗れるものなのでしょうかどうやって予約
すればいいんだろうそうてかサイトでさ
ネットでするイメージしかないからさま新
幹線感覚で空港来ちゃってますし行き先が
ないのもやばいとりあえず国内線のとこ
行きます国内線到着しましたね一番早いの
が10時25分やめなちょっとタイム
ロースがひどいなはいやめましょうやめ
違うなJ1番早いので10時20分の
名古屋行きだから名古屋方面行くのはあり
だったけどちょっと10時まで待つ時間が
もったいないねもっといい便があるはず
です探しましょうすいませんえと当日飛行
機のチケット買いたいんですけどどこで
えっと行き先はどちらでしょう
かえなくてなんか乗れそうな飛行機があれ
ば乗りたいなといういらしゃいましたご
案内しますはいすいません少な線
でまだ乗るの間に合うやつかて何あります
かはにはない
ですなんかは候補がいただけると助かり
ますすいませ
ん早めだと嬉しいなって12時頃まで続く
能なの
が崎札幌
福岡宮崎
大阪鹿児島
高知
松山とかですかなるほどです1番早いやつ
だと何時頃にフライトですか
ね時10終の沖縄駅ですね40分発になる
んですけどね沖縄と北海道多分無理なのよ
行った時点で往復なんか端っこだいぶ
きついと思うかな沖縄ですよね行けるかな
か沖縄からどうやっって本土に帰ればいい
んだそれが8時そうです8時40分発の
到着7時57いやそれ待つ時間より行っ
ちゃった方がいいと思うんだよねそ沖縄で
もいいですかあ
せ様ですはいはい沖縄からといて本土に
戻るんついて速攻もはい
またえでもやえない感じだよねま確かに巻
の巻ではい枝始めで
最速出発できるてことですもんね沖縄が
はいありがとございます完璧ですねこちら
になります意と安くね安安い沖縄3万2
500円2人で平日だからか
ね休日だともっと高いですよねきっとそう
ですねとあと座席の席の数ですね形に
なるほどなるほどはいというわけで飛行機
決まりました沖縄になりましたえ時刻が8
時4分ですねいやはじめさんやる気ないん
すかなんでそんな遠いとこ行っちゃうんす
かて言うと思うんですけどもここしか
なかったんですよ長崎がだって11時とか
て言ってたもんねさすがに11時まで待つ
のであればどこでもいいからどっか行った
方がいいと思うので8時40分出発ですね
あれこれ大丈夫か急がないとやばいなこれ
も着いてからのことを考えますすぐ別の
飛行機に乗りますその予約をもしちゃう
もしもしごめん大君ちょっとお願いがある
んだけど今から飛行機に乗って時40分8
時40分成田発12時10分沖縄に着く
飛行機に乗って沖縄行くんだ
けどすぐ別の飛行機に乗って本土に戻り
たくて九州か東北か行きたくて関西でも
大丈夫役とかってできるかな多分1時間
13時付近のやつであれば多分乗れると
思うんだうんなるべくタイムラグないやつ
に乗れたら嬉しいかな那覇空港初ですい
まてお願いしますはいはいありがとう
助かります優秀なエージェントだついて
から調べるとまたタイムが起きるので沖縄
行きの飛行機が8時40分発の到着が12
時10分結構かかるねまただもうそれで端
っこには行ってるのであとは沖縄から
上がるだけなんですよ九州に行っても良し
だし関西に行ってもよしどっちにしろお昼
までの時間沖縄行く飛行機で潰れちゃうの
でただ端っこには入れれるんでここから
一気に追い上げて北上していければいける
のかなと思います沖縄から九州に行く
フェリー8時間半かかるらしいフェリーの
線はないからもうそこで飛行機に乗るしか
ないので那覇空港で乗り換します別の飛行
にすぐ乗れるように頑張ってみたいと思い
ますでは登場まで待ち
[音楽]
ましょう乗れました思い出し間に合ったね
よかったぞここから4時間飛行機の旅が
始まるんで4時間はスマホも触れないから
ちょっと情報も調べられないとたもう沖縄
行ったら絶対すぐ離れた方がいいね遠い
もんね全てがそうすね多分これ以上飛行機
で時間取られるのもったいないから九州
九州に行く飛行機とりあえず何でもいい
から予約しとけって言っときまし
[音楽]
た
なんか迷必要がちょっと減ったよね沖縄に
来るとは思ってなかったんですけど時間の
都合上まず沖縄に行くしかなかったので
ここから物語を開始し
ます沖縄来まし
たよし人50分ちょっと過ぎなん沖縄
せめて沖縄っぽいもなんかないかめっちゃ
あったかいえ海行きたい海行ってる時間
あるんか海ない近くに諦めようかもう
行こうかというわけで次どうするかと言う
と今が12時25分でしょもう1時間切っ
てます13時20分の飛行機に乗って福岡
に行きますせっかく南の方まで来ちゃっ
てるので近くの九州まずとりあえず行って
そっからどうしようま福岡の博多駅から
こう新幹線でバって稼ぐのもあり大分とか
もさ結構近くになるじゃんそこら辺も
触れれば触りたいよねちょっと終電とかを
調べつつとりあえずチェックインしないと
もう飛行機間に合わないので行きましょう
空港乗り継ぎ
ですゲート行くまで20分ぐらいあるので
ちょっとお昼ご飯食べたいと思います
美味しそうタコライスとか食べたかった
沖縄のはめさんタコライスと楽ラーメン
です終電に近い博多駅から出る新幹線に
乗ってなるべく北まで行くってそれまでに
時間があるのであれば大分とか車で
レンタカーとかして行きたいなと思ってる
んですけどちょっと調べようぜオケー
すちに福岡空港から探しば1時間かかる
おお博多駅から3駅で佐に着きますえマジ
はい新幹線調べてモノレールがあってで大
して帰ってきて高田駅からあ新幹線でも
可能な限
に沖縄沖縄滞在時間1時間切ってます12
時25分に来て
え13時20分の
便つらはいというわけで間に合いました
飛行機14時20分あ13時20分の飛行
機に乗って福岡に行きます福岡空港ここ
からはまあ車も使いつつでも新幹線かな
うん気づいたらもう13時間が経ってます
折り返しが終わってるね今重道府県通って
ますここから頑張れるかどうですね頑張り
[音楽]
ましょうまし
た日はお急ぎの
ところ来ました福岡県
です福岡空港国内客ターミナルはいました
です寒寒いや福岡を俺明日来るんすよ明日
のイベントで福岡来るんですけどもここに
とまるわけにはいかないので行きましょう
か大分とか佐賀とか近いんですけど行った
後往復したり他の県行く時間もなかなか
ないので九州はここで諦めますタクシーに
乗って博多駅向かって新幹線でこな移し
ましょう崎とかも行きたかったんです
けどてよりもっと効率のいい方法がある気
がしてでかいのよね九州が本当
に見といてくださいこの福岡の街並を空港
前ですこれが博多駅までお願いしますはい
新幹線乗り場の方まではい袖ででしょ半袖
ですちょっと沖縄帰りでどれぐらいでつき
そうですかね
10分20分込み具合によりますはい
ありがとうございますここはタクシーで
正解だね正解す
ね新幹線でこっからはどこまで行かれるん
です
か新幹線で今ですねちょっと24時間で都
府県何個回れるかっていう実験をしてまし
て福岡で11都道府県目ですええすごでも
24時間つってもねあれですよねあ
タクシー乗ったりしてもう交通期間は
せめて使ってやってます使ってええ静岡
からスタートし
て関東制覇し
て沖縄行って
福岡来てで九州回ろうと思ったんですけど
ちょっと広いんで岡山まで岡山駅までてで
岡山駅から四国なんか4つぐらいぐるっと
いけないかなと思ってあすごなんか
YouTuberかなんかです
かそのなんか端くれみたいなはい全然
そんなもう眠いよい
ね着きまし
た
ああ新幹線新幹線岡山
行き新幹線走まで4分急ぎましょう
危ねえ行きのびになり
ます間に合いました17時19分17時半
前に着きますあとは停車駅で降りて足を
踏む広島とか山口とかかな岡山までの
ルートで新幹線が止まる場所
でしっかりと降ります1回
まし
[音楽]
たきました山口です山口の皆はいもう無理
無理
無これはカウントで大丈夫
行きました山口だから収めましたよいい
とこだった
な
[音楽]
まし
たこれはもう来たよね
広島ありじゃんこれちゃんと広島という剣
に足ついてますからねさあ次が岡山ですね
次で降り
[音楽]
ましょうりました岡山ですきまし
たただもう17時超えちゃってて暗いよね
もう暗いっすまずいな結構まずいのよこの
後四国行こうと思ってるんですけど4つ
回ろうと思ったんだけど多分無理だね無理
四国4つ回ると多分コチかなコチが奥すぎ
て多分他回れなくなるのでなんとか岡山
からのつ香川愛媛徳島かこの3つなんとか
回れないかなと思ってこの3つ回って四国
をこうなんか横断っぽく岡山から入って
横断してえ新大阪に行って終電に乗ります
新大阪からそのままちょっとまどっか行
行ければいいかなと思ってるんでなでまず
はネタがですね行きましょうとりあえず
岡山はクリアですあと7時間ぐらいつか
ないやばい行ときましょう何個行った
えっと結構行ってるよね
141まだいけるまだいけるまだ行ける
まだ行ける絶対まだけ
岡のレンタカ屋さん着きましたそた
レンタカさんですここで速攻で車を借りて
四国向かいますはいとレタが乗れました
なんかすごかったねめちゃくちゃ混んで
て結構30分ぐらい待ったので結構やばい
どうすればいいんだろうプラン変更しよう
にももう車もレンタルしちゃったからまず
四国向かおうとりあえずお願いしますじゃ
四国へゴーゴー皆さんご覧ください橋です
海の上にいます今多分ナビ見てマジで今
本当に海渡ってんのよこれ多分おおま香川
県に入りまし
たせかだったら香川行きたいよね四国は
行っておきたいただこれ効率悪いムーブ
じゃないと思っててどっちにしろ新大阪駅
には行くと思ってたのでどうせ大阪行くん
だったらちょっと四国も通ってた方がいい
かなと思って遠回りではない若干の遠回り
もそれで2件稼げるのであればすごい
でかいなと思って四国を行っております
すごい見て
めっちゃ
綺麗さすがにお疲れすねさすがに
ねこれ多分だけど24時間生活よりきつい
と思うのようんうんそれもノープランで
やってるわけじゃん0時スタートで常にさ
どう動くっていうのを考えながらやってる
からねなんか脳の疲れがやばいですでも
あそこで沖縄行っといてよかったと思う
よ
来ましたえっとここは香川です香川県の
府中古のパーキングエリアに切りました
時間もそんなないのでパとなんかすぐ行き
ましょうか徳島ラーメンとか香川といえば
やっぱうどんのイメージあるよねあります
香川県のセブンにねヤドンの尻尾でとが
売ってた香川県の香川県でしか売ってない
んかな可愛い買いましたさあ次の
パーキング来ました手を越えて徳島県に来
ました来ました徳島県
ですナルトですねナルトにいますあほらて
ナルトナルト西パーキングエリアギリギリ
ここ香川なんですけどギリギリ徳島の方に
いますね今度ガーって渡って兵庫だよね
兵庫です神戸明石そうだよね兵庫大阪と来
てここで新大阪駅で乗りたいと思います
カロリーメート売ってるんだけどどこにで
もあるカロリー補給しましょうしないと
体力がやばい本当に実はこんなことしてる
場合じゃないのよね多分聞いた方がいいん
だよなはいはい全部剣でゆっくりしたい
本当に本当によしじゃ行きましょうか戻り
ましょうこのまは兵庫行きますお観覧車が
見えてきたということはここは淡路の
サービスエリア
だ淡路のサービスエリアめっちゃいいの
よ俺好きだもんここ普通にましたアです
まし
たこれな今日
淡路島カレーめちゃくちゃおいしくて玉が
ダだそん時間ないです時刻が9時前8時
45分とか8時45分もうす9時でしょ3
時間ちょいしかないんですよちょっと
さすがにここで時間かけてご飯食べてる
時間ないのですぐもう戻って大阪向い
ましょう1分もいなかったを抜けて大阪の
にましょ
はい本州の方に戻り
[音楽]
ますはい大阪入りましただいぶ都会になっ
てきたねもうビルがめっちゃなって
ますすいました新大阪行き
ですはいというわけで新大阪行き着きまし
た時刻が今21時38分あと2時間と
ちょっと残ってますねでえこのレタ感は
ここで乗り捨てますはい何時にどこで
返せるかも何もわかんなかったから指定
できないので明日のお昼にこれ返すことに
なってるんでそれごめんついに任せて俺は
もうここでついともお別れして1人でこの
後は新幹線に乗って24時までどこまで
行ってるか頑張ってみたいとありがとう
ございましたありがとう本当にあとお願い
します任せろよし大阪来まし
たよしよしよしよしよ
よしここからまだ行けるぞ2時間以上ある
わけだ停車駅も含めて1番稼げるのは多分
名古屋に行く新幹線だと思うのでそれ
ちょっと探してみ
ますしばらくお待あり
ござしますただマジ名古屋ついたからどこ
行けばいいんだろうま岐阜か長野ですね
岐阜長野って行ければもう最高だと思う
最後はければいいですけどね新線まであ分
ぐらい待ち
ますいまし
[音楽]
たで次京都なので京都にも行け
ます京都きまし
[音楽]
た22時40分前原駅着きまし
た次の
[音楽]
はよしこれで仕掛けクリアですよし
よご乗車ありがとうございまし岐阜
岐阜岐阜ました岐阜ましたも通るの
かこれであとは次こそ愛知県に行くと思い
[音楽]
ます
あ23時になりました名古屋に着くのが
23時過ぎなので1時間もないねもうね
名古屋から愛知から行けるとしたらあと
長野ぐらいなんですよ頑張って中野向かっ
てみたいと思います無理だったらタクシー
でもいいよちょっと
なんとかして行ってみ
[音楽]
ます
よし名古屋愛知県着きまし
た急げ急げ急げ急げ急げ急げ調べた感じ
多分電車とか特急とかもうなかったですね
23時超えるとなのでもう行く手段がある
とする
とタクシーかなレタしてる時間もない
タクシーで行くしかないですねちょっと
タクシーの運転手さんに聞いてみましょう
が名古屋駅ですはいそれと名古屋ですね
行けるか行けるかお願いします失礼します
はいどちらますちょっと難しいこと言いん
ですけどはい長野県に行きたくて長野県に
はいはいえっと県境でもいいのでもうその
ままもうじゃ中方高速に乗ってって感じ
でしょうかあそうですねはいパーキング
エリアでもサービスエリアでもここでも
オッケーはい降りちゃっていいので分かり
ましたそしたらえっとってきますねはい
すいません意味わかんない内で申し訳ない
です多分トヨタ方面ですよねトヨタ方面
向かっていく感じですよねなんですが縄野
県ですとえっとねこがは超えて坂も超えて
岐阜を突っ切る感じかそう岐阜を突っ切っ
てしまいますなるほどなるほどエ3
トンネルくぐったすぐがその肌っていう
インターになってますんでここで降りれば
一応長野県にはなりますがただ相当返な
場所ですここはなるほどですねもうでも
とりあえず長野県に入れればっていうめさ
じゃそっちの方向かってきますねこはい
すみませんありがとうございよ速に上がっ
て小ジャンクションから中央道入ってき
ます
[音楽]
はい23時59分ギリギリ間に合いました
ね到着しましたもう24時になっちゃうん
かなもうすぐこの企画が始まって24時間
になります
ねあ終了
です企画終了ですさあ果たして私はめは
最後名古屋駅で降りましたタシの運転手
さんに協力していただいて長野の方に
向かいましたどこにいるのかマップ見ます
私が今いる
ところここ
です無理でし
[音楽]
た
間に合いませんでした秒山というところで
終わってしまいましたはめ社長の24時間
都道府県の旅はいというわけで企画終了
です24時間で何個都道府県行けるのかお
疲れ様でしたえ数えてみたところ静岡から
始まり名古屋にりましたなんかうまいこと
ぐるとしたね0時から24時までで合計
22か所行くことができまし
たいやギリ半分行かないかギリ半分行か
なかったですねいや多分あの空港飛行機
乗った時に沖縄行ったのがちょっと良かっ
たのか悪かったのかわかんないんですけど
もフライト3時間半かかったのでそこで
結構タイムロスが起きたような気もしまし
たが結果的にでもその後すぐ福岡に沖縄
から福岡に移動してなんか北に上がる形で
バ行けたのでなんかまこれはこれで良かっ
たのかなと思います他のところを選んで
たらどうなったかとか全くわかんないん
ですけど本当にもう全力を尽くして24
時間走り回った結果22か所回ることが
できまし
た僕
今どこにいるんでしょうジブ山
かタクシも帰っちゃった
しどうしましょう